let's consider a wheel that's rolling so
our wheel is rolling along the surface
the wheel has radius R and I want to
consider the motion of a point P on the
rim of the wheel now I'll choose an
origin that's fixed and in fact here
we're going to talk about the reference
frame a which is fixed to the ground and
I would like to consider my problem is
define both the position of the point on
the rim the velocity of the point on the
rim and the acceleration of the point in
the rim as a function of time now the
position vector is given from my fixed
origin to where the point on the rim is
now this can be quite complicated but
what we're going to do is consider a
second reference frame that is located
at the center of mass of the wheel so
our our second frame will take reference
frame and we'll call this frame CM is
located is moving with the center of
mass of the wheel
so in that reference frame will denote
this point by vector R cm because we're
in the reference frame with respect to
the center of mass and we're talking
about the point P now these vectors are
connected and we'll call this vector
capital R by R vector triangle capital R
equals well little R P that's the
position vector in the fixed frame of
the ground is given by capital R plus R
cm P now as we've seen before by
differentiating the velocity of the
particle is given by the plus the CM P
this one is the velocity in frame fixed
to the ground this is the velocity of
the center of mass
with respect to ground frame and finally
the CMP is the velocity in the center of
mass frame now in order to analyze this
law what will now do is focus on what
the motion looks like if you're an
observer moving with the center of mass
and that's how we'll begin our analysis